good evening ladies and gents my name is
sebastian and today we have officially
reached the final between
magnus and wesley so the first day of
the skilling open
and uh i'm going to show the first game
from the final here with magnus with the
white pieces
so let's take a look d4 knight of six c4
e6 knot of three
magnus started to play knight f3 quite a
lot recently
knight c3 is of course the main move
where the most common continuation
especially before which is called the
nimso indian defense so knight of three
the main move here is t5
now it's c3 and there are a lot of moves
c6s is the some uh the maran variation
or the semi slab
bishop b4 is called a rogozin line a
very interesting uh variation
d take c4 is another is another
interesting line which usually goes like
e3
b5 e5 knight d5
knight xb5 and ip6 complicated stuff
e3 is also possible here with a more
quiet approach with a6 through c5
b7 here is the old nakamura variation
which
i think is a lot more comfortable for
for white and probably the reason why
nakamura stopped playing it
and last but not least is the move that
wesley plays which is c5 and this is the
tarash
defense so very interesting choice here
c takes d5 in here wesley actually takes
here
this is slightly uh slightly strange
but it's very interesting magnus takes
back with uh
the queen i always thought that queen a4
was
not so dumb but apparently it's not the
best way to go nowadays after something
like bishop d7
queen takes d4 he takes d5 and that's
simply
knight c6 next and this is um this is
not so
so clear well white is probably
slightly better but i like magnus's move
here queen takes d4
it's slightly more principled he takes
d5
and here the main move is to strike in
the center with bb4
very very interesting move here which
might lead to an endgame which is indeed
what happens here i can add that
knight c6 bishop b5 doesn't change that
much because black is more or less
forced to take that end game
after d takes e4 queen takes d8 king
takes d8 and then knight g5
and things are fairly similar to to the
game here
so let's go back g takes c4 quint xda
king takes the a knight g5 attacking
both f7
and e4 here bishop e6
is the logical way to continue black
needs to develop
if it does not develop i am going to
play bishop c4
and black is probably already completely
lost
which is quite crazy but he just he has
to play bishop e6 in order to defend the
pawn
so that is the logical way to continue
here
bishop b6 knight takes e6 f takes c6
white has successfully grabbed the
bishop pair but
it's not so easy to claim an advantage
here
but of course this is magnus magnus he
is playing the white pieces
known as the komodo of chess as i
well that's what i like to call him he
he spits out the venom
and the venom kills you eventually it
doesn't kill you immediately
it kills you eventually and um
that's why these positions are very very
fitting for him he's just squeezing
he's squeezing the blood out of the
stone if that makes any sense
probably not all right bishop c4
attacking on e6 so then king e7 is the
way to defend the pawn
if not you can obviously play something
like knight c6 but i wouldn't recommend
giving away this pawn here
something like bishop takes e6 knight d4
and bishop e3
would maybe be playable for black but
i'm not such a fan of this pawn it can
become very weak eventually and i'm sure
why it is doing well here
so king e7 is a move i like protecting
the pawn
simply castles the plan is now bishop g5
oops bishop g5 and rookie one grabbing
on e4
knight bd7 magnus plays bishop e3 here
which is a little bit surprising
i must admit uh
to me not rookie one was slightly more
more logical to just to grab that as
soon as you can and then
something like 95
should be 3 or bishop f1 one of the two
and this is not so dangerous because i
have rook e2
but okay to be fair black is probably
not not doing so badly here either
maybe white is just uh just only
slightly better
so bishop e3 can't be bad but rookie one
was slightly more
logical to me bishop g5 wouldn't been
wouldn't have been that good though
because of king f7
and it's not so easy to win this pawn
any any longer for example rookie one
and then bishop b4 black has a decent
amount of activity
so bishop b3 is played rook c8 attacks
the bishop
should be three and here is another move
that i like knight c5
getting more activity here and
after bishop takes c5 rook takes c5 if
you have an interesting end game
notice these bishops here we have
opposite colored bishops
and this is very drawish
they're infamous or for being rather
rather dry so that is good for the
defending side however
having opposite colored bishops greatly
greatly
favors the attacker so it is slightly
good for white that he has the
initiative here in this position is
simply going to play rookie one and take
on e4
and then he will at least have pressure
the question is if he will be able to
break through because again
we have opposite colored bishops and if
black gets to consolidate
the result is pretty much always a draw
so let's see what happened key one g6
takes only four
takes text e5
already now it's looking more drawish
than what it did the line that was
played was fairly forced
it's not so easy to get through and to
open up the position because with the my
bishop on g7 i defend the target on e5
my bishop might not be very good it's
very passive at least compared to this
bishop here
but it's still quite difficult to create
something due to the lack of
pieces on the board magnus he tries f4
attacking on e5 simply bishop g7 rookie
one
and he wants to win a pawn and
indeed it's not so simple for black to
win that pawn back
but he comes up with something i thought
was clever
to play rook f8 after f takes e5
same play rook f5 now i'm more or less
forced to play
play e6 right at least if i want to win
i can of course play something like h3
but this is a completely
dead drawn end game here so magnus
doesn't want to do that it tries to push
with e6
bishop takes b2 rookie d1
i do believe there was a massive time
trouble at some point
in this game i have to
disclaim that i did not see the game
live
that's uh my bad i'll take that on my
code as we say in the region
but all right let's see what happened
here rook c7
g4 attacking the rook the rook has to
move rook f6
rook f8 one of the two maybe even
rook c5 but you do not want to leave the
f file here because if you do that
i can play something like rook f4 and
now rook f7 and it's getting
very dangerous black needs to be careful
so rook f8 is a good move i think to to
keep control here
and you can see that white has has some
pressure he definitely has some pressure
but is it enough to win
we know we have the komodo of chess here
with white
but is it going to be enough
so king g2 b5 black wants some
counter play here maybe a5 a4 eventually
and try to get rid of this bishop on b3
rook e2 perhaps it's
it's not such a dumb try maybe
um try to double a little bit with rook
d2
it's his plan i think and that's why i
watchedly played bishop c3
preventing rook d2 magnus played rook e3
bishop b4 and the difference now is that
black is contin
is controlling the e7 square with the
bishop this is quite important
because if if i get a rook on let's say
d7
magnus he played rook ed3 if i get a
rook on d7 it's very good that the black
bishop is controlling the e7 square it's
actually vital
it's a difference between a loss and a
victory or a loss in a draw
i mean in many many cases and
we see that in this game especially
let's see what happened
so a5 more activity there rook d7
takes takes king f6 and it's not so easy
to win this game
of course you need to find a way to push
e7
so you need to to get rid of this bishop
somehow and how do you do that
not very easy magnus he tries rook b7
westley plays a4 and here comes a great
great move from magnus he plays g5 and
this is in fact the only way to make
something happen
and this is now tactically because we're
attacking this bishop
and after king takes rook takes b5 white
is attacking the bishop on b4 so this is
quite
quite important we have an important
moment here
magnus was hoping that he would have
enough to win the game
uh
and indeed this is a this is a critical
position
what you do now is black do you play
king of six
or do you play the more forcing move
rook f5
let's calculate rook f5 rook takes b4 a
takes b3 and the end game
we have looks very drawish doesn't it
and this is indeed what we actually saw
so thought so we're gonna take a look at
that
shortly just gonna mention that king of
six would have been better where
this end game here is
very likely to end in a draw for example
bishop b3 and then rook b8
rook a5 and then black needs to try to
hold this
i don't think he's going to have any
problems at all with that but you never
know
magnus is the one with white but when
magnus plays bishop b7 i can
rook a seven i mean um wesley can simply
play this should be seven so there are
no issues
really but wesley he played rook five
instead
and i believe this was the case where
where both players were low on time
magnus takes
the bishop that is the only way to try
to win
and after eight takes b3 the only move
that wins
you can pause the video for a second if
you want to try to find it
but the only move the only move that
wins is one
e sub is e7 here and the point is
that if i play rook e5
magnus is root b5 pinning the rook so
when i take the rook
i i queen
and after b2 i can simply take the rook
so um so this is uh completely winning
we probably get a situation like uh like
this
rook t5 but then i can take the pawn and
it's uh it's winning
so actually didn't do that he took on a2
i'm sure he must have seen this
queen queen
but magnus he is ahead here he is ahead
and he plays queen d7 check
and it's very deep because now wesley
cannot play
queen f6 because if he does that i have
queen e3
and after rook f4 king g3 and then i
will win the rook
at least there's probably something even
better but i think this is
uh everybody sees that this is winning
so it's the easiest
way to show a win and if actually moves
his king
we have this checkmate here which i
wonder what he missed i really wonder
what he missed here
but queen f6 wasn't possible so he tried
king h6
i'm sure he missed this continuation
here rook h4
rook h5 queen f8
he cannot go to g5 and because of queen
of four checkmate
so queen g7 queen f4 the only move is g5
and here queen d6 really important move
and the point is
that after queen g6 queen f8
queen g7 rook takes h5 wins uh
the queen and wesley so resigned
so that was um one hell of a ride
that's for sure really really uh
great game i must say i'm very very well
played by both sides
i think wesley played excellently and he
was unfortunate to blunder there but
that's what happens
in in time travel trouble so well done
by by him
um his only chance was to simply
play king f6 in this position where the
game probably would have ended in
a draw but that's what happens when you
play with short time control it's a lot
easier to blunder and it's certainly not
weird
that it blundered this continuation
right here which is quite long
and um yeah i'm sure he must have
overlooked that
and it's very easy so a great start for
magnus
will mag will wesley so come back from
from his loss it remains to be seen if
he ends up losing the game
he will always get his second chance uh
where everything will be decided so stay
tuned